hello everybody hope that are good that
felt weird to say because it's been
quite a long time since the last video
okay I think it's been two or three
months and it's basically because I'm
traveling right now in qual lumur in
Malaysia but also been couple of months
in Indonesia in Singapore and this might
sound silly but it's the truth guys
traveling ties you up you know when you
are moving between places with your
backback the weight on your shoulders
then you go out to see some temples or
natural w and then you get back to your
hotel you don't really feel like filming
a video I don't know if you understand
me okay so that is basically the reason
why I've been I've prefer to stay on
Twitter and post some tweets every now
and again and trade less I've been
trading less also for the last couple of
months and I was unable to PL some
videos but I'm here in forur to be
honest I feel more relax here I'm taking
him more slow um the rest of the trip is
also less chaotic so hopefully we can
start to PL some more videos regularly
okay and in this first video what I
would like to do is a little analysis
and what has happened in Crypt in the
last few weeks and what could happen in
the next weeks okay what are the
potential scenarios so it's going to be
more like a high time frame view but
also don't worry at the end of the video
we're going to jump into low time frame
trying to find some day trading
opportunities because guys I need to
trade more my trading portfolio has
stayed there for two months not badely
moving it has to move okay so let's jump
into this okay first of all what has
Bitcoin been doing well it's been going
up nonstop right check this out 1 2 3 4
five 6 7 eight eight consecutive green
candles that insane guys I mean if you
go back in the chart tell me when that
was the last time try to find it 1 2 3 4
5 No 1 2 3 No 1 2 3 4 no another 1 2 3 4
5 six seven so you can see that's been
quite a long time okay eight consecutive
green candle so we could say that the
chart looks a ere
extended so take it slow guys also if
you notice this Orange Box is a high
time frame resistance that we are
testing right now and if we see what has
happened previously in this Zone you can
see here okay resistance resistance
support support resistance now we are
back at this level what is going to
happen well it's quite likely that we
see a retrace from here guys don't you
think so um that's what I'm thinking now
I think that the chart looks a bit
overextended if I'm honest with you
eight consecutive green weekly candles
that's quite a lot also are a very
important High time frame resistance so
the chances are that we're going to get
retrace from here now the mat it's going
to be a big retrace or a small retrace
okay that's what matters right now to to
me now now if we look at the chart we're
want to try to find potential correction
targets okay so in the weekly time frame
this is high time frame guys okay this
could happen over the next month two
months three months that's what we're
doing here High time frame weekly time
frame so the first level that I see here
that is quite interesting would be um
this level here is definitely
interesting
31,700 High time frame level support
support
resistance resistance
resistance and we flip this level and we
haven't tested a support just yet so
what I'm saying here is that if we get R
from here it wouldn't surprise me at all
to see a 10,000 drop okay that would be
a 20% correction but again that is not
much when you've been going up 70% okay
that is still going to go up at least a
30% up okay so it's not that bad guys
and I'm not telling you to sell all your
crypto right now here and do an all in
in this song with limit orders because
we might not even get there okay but you
have to be prepared for all the
scenarios and I know it's difficult I
know it's difficult because who is going
to sell you might wonder who is going to
sell when we have the ETF approval
coming soon perhaps in January and if
not in March probably and we also have
the Haring coming in the spring next
year around April March April okay so
who is going to sell well this Market is
extremely emotional so in the moment
that we get some bad news which can come
any time okay say
geopolitical uh news or economic news
okay that are negative then the market
sentiment can switch pretty quickly okay
and there can be sell-offs and then
people start to panic the sell-offs get
bigger and then you can reach targets
that you don't even think they can reach
so you have to be prepared for those
scenarios okay the same as in this one
here you mean we were not all in but we
were also not fully sidelined I charted
uh several alins I don't know how many
we charted I think we charted 20 or 25
five of them got triggered in The Bu
zones so at least me and anybody that
follow those Alcon updates were able to
write some of this wave with alcons okay
um those five alons um they've been
doing pretty pretty good to be honest
well I'll probably make a new video this
week about the ALCO Market to date um
and tell you what I think okay but
that's what I mean don't put all your
eggs in one basket and that means that
take some profits here if you are swing
trading why wouldn't you take profits
here at high time frame resistance and
also after eight consecutive graen
candles okay that's what I'm trying to
say the same as when we were here I
wouldn't tell you to be sidelined okay
because that's all support all your X in
one basket be prepared for both
scenarios okay um do I think that price
can do something like
this I
mean it's possible okay but eight
consecutive green candles the ODS in my
opinion are more than we see a
correction from here that correction
again it can be a 3,000 4,000 5,000 or
10,000
correction okay that is a difficult
thing to guess but for now only based on
the highest time high time frame levels
on the most important levels then the
first very important level that I see in
the chart is right here
31,700 and that is what I would add
altcoins to my portfolio if we see a
pullback okay because you're also going
to have the weekly 50 ma coming through
and that is going to be um also adding
support to that Z okay because if you
notice what the 50 EMA in the weekly
time frame has been doing all this time
is support resistance well here again
support then here resistance okay then
support here that was some kind of fake
out then again support goes up so you
know something like
this can still happen Okay that you go
all the way down to 31,000 and again
it's not bad thing because you can if
you are prepared you can add to your to
your to your portfolio that okay and
that would be a good opportunity
now um that's to me the scenario that um
I think it has more chances that in the
next few months before the ETF and the
halin there are some news and you come
to 31k again that's quite likely to me
then if you break through that zone then
you have obviously lower targets such as
25k okay also an important level
resistance support support again
resistance here okay and if you drop
below below that level then you can go
towards that week here that we left most
of the weeks get filled if you check
over the chart you want to find out the
98% of weeks get filled at some point so
is this week going to get filled at some
point or are we going to leave it there
at it's possible we leave it there okay
now 20K seems a bit difficult to get and
I don't think we're going to get that
again possibly okay at least with
information that we have now anything
can change okay but as some an
aggressive Target I think 31,000 can
happen again so that's my high time
frame View and all I'm trying to say is
to be prepared for any scenario okay if
a correction comes if a gra of
Correction like this the 31,700 comes
that's a gift okay and you have to be
able to take that opportunity so that's
what I'm trying to say be prepared be
prepared because anything can happen I
know we have a lot of bullish news at
the moment but things can change pretty
quickly and we've going we've been going
up for it consecutive weeks so you know
mean you're also testing a high time
frame resistance so a correction can
happen from here the question is how big
is the correction going to be okay and I
know that you guys are feeling most of
you very bullish even my dad is euphoric
he's telling me 100k for first quarter
of 2024 so I mean let's see what happens
okay I personally don't see 100K um that
quick I think it's more likely to see
maybe a correction here maybe some more
ranging and mean we'll see what happen
after the ATF gets approved that that
could happen in January or it could
happen in March okay and then we have
the halin in March or April in the
spring okay so um be prepared be
prepared for that scenario too okay
that's what I'm trying to say so um
that's what I think I think in my
opinion this High time frame level um
it's not a bad idea to take some profits
okay I'm personally taking some profits
from the from the AL coins that got
triggered there are not many but I think
it's still a good level to take some
someone of the table okay now if you go
into lower time frame and try to see why
it's happening today we go into the four
our time frame and sorry there you go um
I'm going to remove this two we can see
how we've gone to the top of this
resistance at
42,300 okay we got rejected there and
now we are consolidating here to be
honest if we want to get more
information we go into the 1 hour time
frame and what do we see here okay we
see that we haven't tested the one or 50
minut for quite some time overextended
it's likely that we get that test but if
you notice look at the highs you see the
same as me that's a week okay now if you
mark the 50% that'll go around
42215 okay that is a level that we are
going to see again so what am I looking
at well the the question is are we going
to go towards that 50% of the week first
or sorry or is it more likely that you
know we continue dropping test the one
out 50 41,000 then hold this level as
support okay and then you can go towards
that 50% of the week that's what I'm
paying attention to right now at the
moment okay I would like to see that I
would like to see a drop towards the 1
or 15a hold a level of support and then
I see
but there is a reason why the price
could go up again could visit the the
highs again and that is that week okay
remember at least 98% of weeks get
filled so are you telling me that this
one is not going to get filled it's
going to be an exception the chances are
that it's going to get filled okay so
something like this is ideally what I
would like to see if I'm honest with you
1 hour 50 m test then we long it if he
holds a support towards that 50% of the
week now is it possible that we drop
less or we even got from here of course
yes um that would be in my
opinion this Zone over here
okay this Zone over here it's quite
tight okay you have this liquidity pool
over here okay that's a large that's a
big candle that has left an imbalance
behind that's a liquidity pool and this
could also get filled and then instead
of dropping all the way to the 1 hour 50
may we can actually go up from here okay
so these are the two levels that I'm
looking too long if I'm honest with you
1 hour 50 ma
ideally but the chances are also that we
drop towards this liquidity pool hold it
and then go up again towards that week
so
um is this momentum
sifting it's too soon to tell in my
opinion momentum cannot tell you s yet
okay it could be quite similar
to for example something like this okay
that could be quite similar to what
we're seeing right now if you notice
okay you have here some kind of an M
pattern and then you go to the one of 50
Ma you consolidate and you go up again
okay it's that the same this is this an
information consolidation here and then
go up again could happen Okay so again
it's not it's too soon to say if this is
um momentum sifting or just a small
range before going up again uh for now
the trend is up I don't see momentum
sifting yet so I don't see reasons to
start um taking a shorts in day trading
is safer to favor Longs at the moment so
all that I'm looking at is areas well
support zones where I can long again and
that is the 1 50 Main and this Zone over
here okay and the target is the
50% of that week at 42,2 so that's why
I'm seeing in the lower time frame guys
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you soon